America's First Noel after eight years
of tinsel for a Happy Holidays humbug
hurry and you better believe the card
watchers over at FoxNews well they
notice delivering on one of his campaign
promises the first family I just
released their Christmas card where they
do in fact wish everybody a Merry
Christmas and Happy New Year a little
different than the the President Obama's
Christmas card from last year where he
wished everybody a more politically
correct Happy Holidays yeah that Obama
Christmas card was one of the most
offensive cards I've ever not gotten
but now Christmas is center stage again
yesterday Trump gave a speech on tax
reform now this this is the kind of
November policy speech where Obama
wouldn't have mentioned Christmas once
not my president
together we will give the American
people a big beautiful Christmas present
I said gonna have Christmas skin you
don't see Merry Christmas anymore
with Trump as your president we are
going to be celebrating Merry Christmas
again yes
people forget that the full name of the
holiday is Merry Christmas you see the
White House this year
Christ is everywhere a nativity scene
return to the White House for the first
time since 2016 you could tell the wise
men are more streetwise and let's book
wise with Trump at the helm Christmas
somehow feels I don't know whiter we
want Christmas is back in America where
it started but we can't afford to gloat
as with everything else great about our
country foreign nations are jealous and
will do whatever they can to ruin
Christmas threats are bound we have to
stay vigilant and no one is more
vigilant when it comes to Christmas and
the opposition's jingle boots on the
ground
Aaron Jackson and Josh our God feels
good to say that again no good care for
some of this chocolate saying no Jordan
no that could be a Trojan Santa from
Germany where the bad Nazis are from
whoa
throat Trojan Santa what do you mean
well as you know we are on the forefront
of global gay news comes to us through
the wind jardín anyway according to the
wind and also Breitbart German
supermarket chain penny has introduced a
new line of rainbow gay talk ilat
Santa's just in time to ruin Christmas
Jordan Germany is trying to replace our
God loving red-blooded American Santa
you can't do that to Santa he's one of
the main characters in the Bible
remember the Gospels Matthew Mark Luke
and Santa and furthermore you can't tell
the world that Santa is gay yeah that's
a secret what what yeah Jordan I've
heard that Santa is gay from one of my
exes wait which one oh the elf who made
toys oh my god he was so hot but I hated
how he treated you um anyways this
globalists conspiracy clicked when we
heard these rainbow gay talk 'let
Santa's were meant to promote diversity
tolerance and love everybody knows or
liberal dog whistles for political
correct yeah gross so where's this next
attack on Christmas coming from I'll
give you three guesses Jordan China
China or China right I gotta go with it
Ron Jordan its China real American
Christmas tree farmers are being put out
of business by fake Chinese tree farmers
growing fake plastic trees fake plastic
trees my third favorite cold place off
mine's creep creep that's a video yeah
yeah we love it now Jordan in a way I
blame myself for this Chinese incursion
first they came for our Louis Vuitton
bags and I said nothing
in fact I bought seven and now this so
how do we stop them well simple Jordan
America first don't even go to a tree
farm who knows where those seeds came
from yeah go right to your own American
backyard and rip that tree out of the
ground with your own American hands then
take a slice out of that and count the
rings in the trunk if it's a Chinese
number throw it away what's uh what's
what's a Chinese num I don't know Jordan
six eleven you can't be too careful yeah
China and numbers what a nightmare well
I hope you're wearing your rubber boxer
briefs Jordan because we've saved the
worst for last yes the upside-down
christmas tree you can buy it for a cool
grand i mean it's everything that is
wrong if you don't want to participate
in christmas or hanukkah what if your
holiday is you don't have to but i don't
even know when upside-down christmas
tree means I'm with Corey this is insane
what's next an upside-down wreath can
you even picture that Oh what why on
earth would anyone do this this inverted
pyramid is clearly a message from the
Illuminati yeah what stands on the top
of trees angel and if you turn the tree
upside down what happens the angel falls
who's a fallen angel Lucifer so
so you're saying this globalist attack
on Christmas is actually from hell hell
China Germany I don't know but it's one
of those horrible places you go when you
die and hold on to your Jordan because
the attack on Christmas is closer than
you say yeah
the President himself recently invited
reporters to a holiday reception and
Queen Melania tweeted just the other day
preparations are underway to celebrate
the holidays at the White House Christ
so anyone could be compromised yes
Jordan even our Feliz Maga dad
[Music]